Jackson wrote in what's the most and
least impressive tourist attraction that
you've ever seen least impressive I hate
to say this because on the one hand I
love science and it and it sounds like
it would be really cool but in South
Hadley Massachusetts I believe it is
there are dinosaur footprints and
growing up in western Massachusetts I
went on so many field trips to these
dinosaur footprints and it's basically
it's almost not even noticeable at the
site of some Road I think it's on
highway 116 route 116 and Western Mass
the school bus pulls over and you're not
sure if the school bus is pulling over
so that the bus driver can urinate
because we're not near a bathroom or if
we're actually at the dinosaur footprint
and you're at the dinosaur footprints
and it's just barely visible imprints on
a couple of rocks it's not a tourist
attraction per se although many tourists
come to Western Massachusetts and go to
see these footprints and it was just so
lame what about Plymouth Rock -
obviously this is getting very
Massachusetts oriented but it's
something that you hear about so much as
you know an important mark of our
history and yet if you go there's just
some small boulder with the year 1620
inscribed onto it I remember going when
I was in like fifth grade or something
and the other thing is that Plymouth is
kind of it it has a middle of nowhere
but Plymouth Massachusetts is well
outside of Boston there's really nothing
else there you show up and there's this
rock and it is kind of underwhelming I
think that's why they put Mount Rushmore
in South Dakota in the middle of nowhere
how do you get people to go to the
middle of nowhere yeah make something
like that yeah and and how about like
most impressive tourist attractions
you've been to I said for me I teach in
Itza in Mexico is absolutely fascinating
one of the seven wonders of the world
and just thinking and imagining how this
was built yeah so long ago that to me
was one of the most impressive and to
really to understand it you need to be
have you need to be with someone who's
going to explain to you what you're
seeing because if you just see this
rundown pyramid and what looks like a
small soccer field or whatever you're
not going to understand everything that
took place there in the context in which
it was created
yeah the same idea I would pick
Stonehenge of course something mated
3,000 BC and you know there was no
source of rock anywhere in that vicinity
right we don't even know what it was
used for was the calendar was it some
sort of religious symbol I mean the
mystery is what makes that fast have you
we just don't have oh I've never been
I've never been you have far outside of
London is you can take a day trip I mean
yeah within a couple hours you can get
the Stonehenge from Wow Wow and then of
course as we found out what were your
British heritage right it was a very
apropos yeah for you I mean you could
say that my ancestors might have I'm
going to say they did we certainly can't
rule it out it melts fair to say other
impressive tourist attractions I mean
certainly the old city of Jerusalem is
just unbelievable I mean the feeling of
history that you get there and although
unfortunately some areas of it have had
to sort of be rebuilt because of
vandalism during the 40s and 50s who
would vandalize something that historic
I mean it's hard for me to imagine but
in any case that is absolutely
fascinating the Eiffel Tower because you
have a picture of it up
I love the Eiffel Tower it doesn't
strike me as so impressive although
understanding the construction that
wouldn't went into it at the time is
interesting well speaking of French
architecture what do you think about the
Statue of Liberty because that's thought
of as maybe our top landmark in the
entire country yeah and you know it's
nice if you go to Liberty Island I guess
but seeing it from afar doesn't really
do it for me yeah I mean it's a nice
little gift that the French gave us so
nice yeah it was it was nice of them but
it wasn't certainly one of the most
impressive tourist attractions I've been
to